this morning the president calls it a
travesty of justice that a San Francisco
jury found five times deported Mexican
man not guilty of murder
Jose Ynez Garcia Zarate was charged with
killing Kate Steinle in 2015 this case
stirred up a fierce national debate over
illegal immigration John Blackstone is
in San Francisco with the latest John
good morning good morning well outside
the courtroom the killing of Kate
Steinle was all about illegal
immigration and sanctuary cities like
here in San Francisco but inside the
courtroom the only thing at issue was
whether Stein Lee's killing was
intentional or a tragic accident
following the not guilty verdict defense
attorney Matt Gonzalez condemned the way
the case had been politicized by
President Trump and Attorney General
Jeff Sessions and they may themselves
soon avail themselves of the presumption
of innocence and beyond a reasonable
doubt standard and so I would ask them
to reflect on that before they comment
or disparage the result in this case
about three hours later President Trump
tweeted a disgraceful verdict no wonder
the people of our country are so angry
with illegal immigration the killing
became a centerpiece of Donald Trump's
presidential campaign another victim is
Kate Steinle gunned down in the
sanctuary city of San Francisco Kate
Steinle was walking with her father on a
San Francisco pier when the 32 year old
was shot in the back soon after police
arrested Hosea Nez Garcia Zarate an
undocumented immigrant who'd been
deported to Mexico five times he'd
recently been released from the San
Francisco jail but under sanctuary city
policies had not been turned over to
immigration authorities in court however
defense attorneys argued Garcia's errata
found the gun under a bench on the pier
and it fired accidently the bullet
ricocheted and hit Steinle 78 feet away
Garcia zarada is not a free man he was
found guilty of illegal possession of a
firearm that carries a sentence of up to
three years and he also faces
deportation again Gael all right thank
you John